on commence avec cette petite révolution
à cuba
à presque 80 ans après 47 ans de pouvoir
sans partage fidel castro a décidé de
confier provisoirement les rênes du
pouvoir à son frère raul
le temps at il dit de se remettre d'une
opération chirurgicale à l'intestin
bertrand cocq depuis quelques années on
le savait fatigué usé par 48 ans d'un
pouvoir sans partage
à quelques jours de son 80e anniversaire
le vieux dictateur communiste a fait
savoir que des ennuis de santé l'obligé
à passer la main provisoirement le
communiqué lu hier soir à la télévision
par son secrétaire particulier invoque
le surmenage pour expliquer une crise
intestinale aiguë qui a nécessité une
opération chirurgicale complexe
fidel castro qui parle d'une absence de
plusieurs semaines délègue tous ses
pouvoirs à son petit frère raul de cinq
ans son cadet ce communiste orthodoxe
dirigé d'une main de fer les forces
armées cubaine sur le malecon l'avenue
principale de la havane et les réactions
sont convenus ouvert nesto il semble que
le commandant est abusé de sa santé il
devrait faire plus attention à lui
je veux qu'il aille très vite mieux et
que tout continue comme avant affirme
eduardo le pousse-pousse de la havane
depuis la révolution de 59 c'est la
première fois que fidel castro abandonne
ses responsabilités depuis près d'un
demi siècle
le lider maximo nargue les américains il
a survécu à l'effondrement du communisme
et à la disparition de l'urss et
semblait même avoir trouvé une seconde
jeunesse à travers les succès de ses
disciples et allié hugo chavez le
vénézuélien et plus récemment le
bolivien evo morales
mais ces derniers temps l'homme des
discours fleuves donnait des signes de
fatigue malaise en public et même cette
chute spectaculaire
il ya deux ans lors d'un meeting après
l'annnonce de son retrait provisoire des
milliers de cubains exilés aux etats
unis sont descendus dans la rue à miami
pour manifester leur joie aux cris de
vive cuba libre